Captain America Civil War's gonna be the
first time we're gonna see spider-man
participating in a major Marvel
Cinematic Universe event but my question
is how many major Marvel events has
spider-man participated in and played
some key role let's find out now let me
preface this by saying this list does
not include spider centric events like
maximum carnage or Spider Island
these are Marvel Comics company
crossover events that are not spider-man
centric but like the upcoming Civil War
movie still include spider-man in some
significant way for example I'm not
going to include 1982's contest of
Champions because while Grand Master and
death did summon spider-man among every
hero in the Marvel Universe spider-man
doesn't even fight in that battle
however I would include 1973's the
Thanos war rather the aftermath several
prominent heroes are captured but it's
thanks largely in part to spider-man
that they were freed and Thanos was
ultimately defeated the next significant
event which spider-man plays a crucial
role is in 1984 Secret Wars spider-man
single-handedly defeats the x-men
assists in every significant battle
using a spider sense and even discovers
his alien symbiotic costume for good
measure in the follow-up in 1985 Secret
Wars to the Beyonder actually goes to
Peter Parker's apartment and they have
kind of a heart-to-heart about humanity
while spider-man doesn't strategize with
the new mutants or even throw a punch
for that matter he does talk beyond her
down from a tamper tantrum that could
have destroyed the universe I'd say
that's pretty significant in the 1988
x-men event Inferno the x-men deal with
Madeline Pryor turning into a goblin
queen and literal demons come to earth
and it's in several different spider
titles that spider-man has to deal with
those feelings one of which includes the
spider-man villain Hobgoblin who later
actually becomes demo goblin as a direct
result of the infernal crossover in the
1989 marvel cross
prevent atlanta's attacks in the only
moment in which Atlantis actually
attacks
spider-man is on the front lines along
with the Fantastic Four to keep the
force of Atlantis at bay yet again in
1989 the acts of vengeance saga saw
different Marvel Comics villains
swapping heroes to see if their
familiarity was what was giving them the
edge in this story arc both Magneto and
the Tri Sentinel thanks to Loki attack
spider-man and both time spider-man
succeeds with a little help from the
Enigma force in 1991 the mad Titan known
as Thanos takes control of all infinity
gems and kills half the universe in an
event called the Infinity Gauntlet all
the Marvel heroes band together to
figure out what to do about this problem
spider-man winds up going all the way to
Thanos his lair where he is promptly
beaten to death by a creepy female
version of Thanos that he created to
make death jealous named her Axia after
the events of the Infinity Gauntlet Adam
warlock gains control of it and in 1992
reconstitutes his evil persona known as
the mages it's during this infinity war
that the mages creates an alternate
reality where there are evil
doppelganger versions of all the
superheroes including spider-man this
mindless spider doppelganger would have
wreaked havoc across New York City of
spider-man in the Hobgoblin hadn't
defeated it it was of course promptly
captured by demo goblin and then teamed
up with the carnage crew during maximum
carnage but that's another video in
1993's infinity crusade the Adam warlock
good personality becomes an entity known
as the goddess the God has collected
several cosmic artifacts in order to
create a cosmic egg which uses to create
an entire paradise planet she manages to
brainwash and call any character that
has a belief system including spider-man
and transforms him into a mindless
zealot ready to defend the goddess and
her plans thanks to the combined might
of Thanos Adam warlock and Professor X
all the heroes are returned to the
normal states and back to where they
belong in 1996 is the onslaught Saga the
combined consciousness of Professor
Xavier and Magneto formed an evil
psychic entity known as onslaught who
attempted to destroy all of humanity
while this was during the Clone Saga
spider-man and then Riley teamed up to
battle a rogue Sentinel control by
onslaught to attack regular New Yorkers
the two spider-men defeated The Sentinel
and swung towards Central Park where the
huge climactic battle of onslaught was
brewing between the combined might of
the x-men and Avengers and onslaught
himself neither of them were seen at the
battle however and no one bothers to
explain why in 2004's Avengers
disassembled Scarlet Witch aka Wanda
Maximoff went bonkers and killed most of
the Avengers in
suing battle to bring her down every
superhero in the New York area including
spider-man joined together to help their
fallen comrades
spider-man assists in the Kree invasion
that was conjured by Wanda and is
present at the climactic battle in which
Wanda takes all of the heroes greatest
fears and turns and against each other
spider-man's greatest fear by the way
clones in 2004 Nick Fury waged a secret
war against Lucia von barda's the
American installed leader of Latveria
after Doctor Doom was seemingly killed
as it turns out she was funneling money
into the tinkerer who was creating
weapons and augmented suits for super
villains to attack on American soil
spider-man was one of the few people
that Nick Fury called who owed him a
favor and along with other heroes like
Luke Cage and Wolverine spider-man
helped fight a war in Latveria against
the dictator herself
one year later spider-man had to fight
another secret war which was in
retaliation for their first attack while
spider-man doesn't do any major
significant thing there are so few
members of the secret war that it's
worth noting in 2005's House of them
Wanda maximov and her brother Pietro
used Wanda's reality altering powers to
give Wanda back her children and give
all their friends and family everything
they've ever wanted in Peter Parker's
case it meant a life as spider-man but
with Uncle Ben and Gwen Stacy's still
alive with fame and fortune after
Wolverine and plot device Lela Miller
gave back Peter Parker's original
memories he was instrumental in the
fight against the forces of the House of
M when all was said and done the world
was put back to the way it used to be
but Peter Parker retained the memories
of his alternate life backing up Tony
Stark's support of the superhuman
Registration Act in 2005 civil war
Spiderman revealed his identity as Peter
Parker to the whole world in solidarity
after the unintended death of Bill
Foster aka Goliath Peter Parker realized
he was on the wrong side of this
argument and he joined with Captain
America and his anti-registration forces
this decision along with his identity
revealed would utterly ruin his life
at that point and he soon became a
fugitive from the law along with his
ante registration comrades in the
climactic battle of civil war spider-man
was instrumental in taking down Pro
Registration forces like mr. fantastic
2007's World War Hulk saw the Hulk
returned to Earth to seek revenge
against the Illuminati which included
Iron Man mr. fantastic Black Bolt and
Doctor Strange
before the Hulk and his warbound could
arrive in New York City spider-man and
the Avengers helped evacuate the city of
innocent civilians and tried to help
defend the city by battling the warbound
Hulk's comrades in 2008 Secret Invasion
spider-man was one of the many heroes
that was copied by the scrolls during
their invasion and he stood United with
both Avengers teams to battle the
invading
scroll forces in Central Park at the end
in 2009's Dark Reign spiderman villain
norman osborn took over shield and
changed it to hammer and formed his own
Avengers squad during this time the
realm known as Asgard was floating above
Broxton Oklahoma this led into the 2010
event siege in which Norman Osborn's
Avengers squad invaded as gone all the
Avengers which included spider-man rose
up and defended Asgard and when the
center went crazy and turned back into
the void and attacked everybody Loki
offered enchanted Norn stones to the
Avengers forces which included
spider-man which augmented their powers
and strength to become a force to be
reckoned with in the end the century was
killed in Norman Osborn was revealed to
be the Goblin he really is and
spider-man got the final blow in 2010
daredevil was infected by a demon and
took over Hell's Kitchen and renamed its
shadow land his fellow street-level
heroes including Luke Cage iron fist and
spider-man tried to shake him out of it
but it was too little too late
spider-man did take down daredevil
villain as typhoid mary though in 2011's
event fear itself' the Asgardian god of
fear known as the serpent was
resurrected by the red skulls daughter
known as sin wielding an enchanted
hammer not unlike Thor's she became
scotty herald of the serpent releasing
more evil enchanted hammers and
spreading worldwide panic it was up to a
unified avengers to stop it
working in Odin's workshop Tony Stark
built weapons for all of his Avengers
comrades including enchanted Blade II
gauntlets for spider-man in 2012's
Avengers vs. x-men the Phoenix force
threatened to return to earth in the
body of Hope Summers in an attempt to
keep the Phoenix force at bay the
Avengers took Hope Summers to Kunlun a
mystical city the iron fist is very
familiar with and while training there
spider-man taught hope about great power
and great responsibility in 2013's age
of Ultron Ultron took over the world and
killed nearly everybody a small pocket
of Avengers force a save spider-man and
brought him into a secret bunker where
one contingent went to the future to
battle Ultron and Wolverine went back in
time and kind of messed up everything
even more but spider-man just kind of
stayed behind he's one of the few
characters who doesn't die in 2014's
event original sin d-list villain The
Orb steals uatu the watcher's eye and
uses it as a knowledge bomb on nearly
the entire superhero community
spider-man is given the revelation that
the spider that bit him actually bit
somebody else before dying and he
totally bails in the entire fight to go
find her 2014 event access included the
Red Skull turning into onslaught after
stealing Xavier zhh brain and putting it
into his
edie in an attempt to flip the axis and
give Charles Xavier control over his own
mind in the red skulls body dr. strange
and Scarlet Witch tried to cast an
inversion spell that wound up getting
attacked by sentinels before they could
finish it in a twist of fate most of the
heroes were inverted to evil and most of
the villains were inverted to good
spider-man's would have a few heroes
will avoid the inversion and winds up
trying to help everybody else put things
back to the way they were and stop
apocalypses gene balm which would have
killed all humans
spider-man attempts to stop the gene
bomb with his webbing but is stopped by
carnage who warns him his efforts will
fail the carnage seemingly sacrifices
his life to stop the bomb it's
spider-man t-rex an entirely tasteless
statue as per Carnage's request in his
honor in 2015 secret wars all worlds
were colliding in the form of incursions
the final incursion was between the 616
original Marvel Universe and the
Ultimate Universe before being destroyed
Reed Richards built a life raft and
grabbed it as many superheroes and
friends as he could which included
spider-man the raft lay dormant for some
time before being opened by Doctor
Strange now known as Stephen strange in
an alternate world known as battle world
controlled by God King dr. doom Peter
Parker spider-man and counterpart Miles
Morales spider-man entered a secret
chamber which housed the secret power of
God King tomb also known as Owen Reese
the molecule man while Peter Parker
doesn't do anything specifically helpful
in this situation Miles Morales does
offer own Ray's a burger which allows
him and his family to be preserved in
the Marvel prime universe and finally in
civil war - spider-man will be on the
opposing side of Iron Man in this new
conflict between superhero communities
the central story is between Captain
Marvel and Iron Man coming to blows over
and inhuman who can see into the future
and whether they should use that power
to stop crimes before they start not
much is yet known about Peter Parker's
involvement in this conflict but we can
guess it's going to be pretty big so
there you have a gang spider-man's role
in nearly every Marvel Comics crossover
event since 1973 and while Spiderman
didn't always throw the last punch or
say the last word he always played a key
role in some way is sometimes thanks a
lot for watching sorry I'm not robbed
and we'll see you guys next time on
comics explained and if you liked what
you heard you can stop by comic pop and
check out what we've got going on